all right I thank you Jeannie for the
introduction and let's get started all
right I thanks so much for having us
today guys I'm Anna and as Jeannie said
we're as premier said I'm from
Massachusetts currently working at Mount
Sinai in a research lab there and I am
originally from Lawrence Kansas and I'm
currently a second year PhD student at
Rockefeller University so we just wanted
to introduce a little bit more about
ourselves and what we've been doing
during the pandemic like money I've been
working on my research from home here in
Queens and frequently skyping my family
my parents adopted a puppy back in
January and so I've been watching him
grow via FaceTime I've also for the past
two months been helping at Mount Sinai
running Cobin 19 antibody testing and so
this is a picture I took of the sunrise
from the lab in which we were doing that
testing I've I'm not in a hospital so
I've not been helping reduce spread of
the pandemic I've been playing a lot of
animal crossing this was me and my
friend Steph hanging out because we
can't in real life I've also been
skyping my dogs and when they kind of
make us over some day I hope to go see
Steph and my other friends in real life
see live shows and hopefully get to
visit my friend Amanda's chameleon who
she got shortly before the pandemic
started and keeps in lab ok so in
addition to all of that something we've
been doing during this 10 Demick is
learning more about
kovin 19 and about the you know
implications for society and for
ourselves and so we came across this
paper that we found particularly
interesting that we want to share with
you today titled feasibility of
controlling Kovan 19 outbreaks by
isolation of cases and contacts and so
you'll notice in this title there's a
couple key words that we're going to
talk more about
but you'll see the word isolation which
is going to come up a lot and also this
idea of contact and so this paper uses
models and math to try and investigate
approaches to controlling this Koba 19
outbreak so to start I'll talk a little
bit about the types of scientific
reasoning that are used in this paper
unlike some of the other presentations
we've had that have been about
experimental research this paper uses
first the idea of hypothetical modeling
so with this approach scientists look at
the world around them and they observe
complex phenomena and then they try to
distill these phenomena down to the key
components and the key interactions that
make up that phenomena so then you have
a tractable problem that you can
investigate with mathematics the second
tool that they use in conjunction is the
idea of probabilistic reasoning so I
this technique uses statistics to look
at large data sets and to try and find
patterns in them to make sense of all of
the numbers so Oh
Deveney thanks we're next gonna look at
the people who perform this research to
get a better idea of where this is
coming from so this is research done by
the Center for mathematical modeling of
infectious diseases it's based out of
London in the UK and what the Institute
does is they use data to understand the
natural history and epidemiology of
infectious diseases to help us predict
the course of current and future
pandemics and importantly to assess
different policy options in order to
improve public health
during these crises they also conduct
research on how to fit complex models to
new data that we get and they develop
new methods to survey hard to reach
population
okay so first we're gonna talk just a
little bit more about what is a
mathematical model and in particular
what is the type of mathematical model
that is being used in this paper in
other words what are we trying to model
and how are we going to do that so as I
mentioned before a mathematical model is
going to distill some complicated
phenomena down into key components and
key interactions so if our goal is to
model a pandemic or the spread of
infectious disease the key components
that we might think about are the person
on the right so one type of person who
is an infected person this person has
the disease another key component are
going to be all of the uninfected people
here shown in blue and then the
interactions that we're going to be
trying to model are the contact and
spread of the disease from infected
people to uninfected people so that's
represented here by an arrow so we know
that in real life there's a lost you can
you hear me know yeah it's pretty good
you can't hear me yes okay all right I
will keep going then let me know if my
audio cuts out okay so uh where was I
yeah okay
so we know that in real life there's a
lot of chance that's actually involved
on an individual level
did we lose life yeah I I don't know if
you want to reshare the screen or if you
need me to do it
Stephanie I think you're muted
okay there we go yeah cool okay sorry
everybody
oh this is okay I mean we're all on
doing all the time if nobody's used to
technical difficulties by now then they
haven't been on zoom' enough thank heart
thanks guys
okay so there's a lot of chance involved
in this right like you might walk past
an infected person and maybe you'll get
sick but maybe you won't and so we we
explicitly model the role of chance in
this mathematical model and you can
think about this functioning kind of
like the roll of a dice so if we have
this one infected person they coming
into contact with the person on the left
and we're gonna roll a dice and say okay
if we roll a six
for example our person on the left will
become infected but if we roll any other
number then the person will remain
uninfected so that's one single
interaction but we're gonna have a
series of interactions that we need to
play out within this model so if that
first person say we rolled a six they
become infected now we're gonna have to
roll the dice again to model how that
second person interacts with the rest of
the people so this is going to be an
iterative process and we're going to be
modeling how the proportion not the
proportion just the total number of
infected people changes over time
according to the set of rules that we
define great so we're gonna take the
mathematical model that and I just
described and what this paper does is
they write this all out in code and use
that to run a lot of simulations with a
lot of infected people in the order of
thousands very very quickly and you
could do all of this out on paper and
like roll a real physical die obviously
that would take a very a long time so
the thing that simulations give us is a
lot of information about how scenarios
could play out in lots of different ways
because again the die gives us an
element
random chance but we want to know on
average what is going to happen for a
certain number of people and a virus
those certain infectivity so we're going
to get into how to do that now first
we're gonna define a few key terms
before we get into the meat of the paper
and those terms are going to be
isolation quarantine and contact tracing
okay so I'll cover the first two terms
which we saw the term isolation in the
title of the paper and both of these
terms are probably ones that you are
somewhat familiar with having read them
in the news and I know for myself I use
these words somewhat interchangeably and
sort of sometimes to mean different
things but in the context of this paper
and scientifically they actually have
distinct definitions so isolation is the
separation of sick individuals so people
who are showing symptoms we know that
they are sick away from others whereas
quarantine is the separation of someone
who has had contact with a sick person
away from others so with isolation say
we have this one infected person who's
and so something that's that's important
to note here which I think we're all
familiar with do to do to Kovan 19 is
that with this disease there is a period
where you can become infected so you are
technically sick but you are not yet
showing symptoms and during that period
it's still possible to infect other
people so this person in red is sick but
does not yet have any symptoms so he
doesn't know he's sick he comes into
contact and you know based on chance
happens to infect this other person
potentially we don't know yet but then
he himself becomes sick and so now he
realizes oh I'm feeling sick we can put
him in isolation to prevent him from
coming into contact with any more people
hi since he already has come into
contact with some people
while he had the disease he there's
there's still a means of passing the
virus on to other people but we're
limiting the number of people that this
occurs to in quarantine we're taking
action a little bit earlier so we have
our one infected person who's coming
into contact with others but for
quarantine as soon as we realize that
that infected person is sick as soon as
they have symptoms we're going to
separate out not only that one person
but also all of the people that they've
come into contact with who could
potentially be sick so that prevents the
spread from those secondary people onto
others so in this case maybe only one of
those four people actually did get sick
so so you can see from this picture from
the simple cartoon that the method of
quarantine is more resource intensive
than the method of isolation you're
you're putting more people you're
forcing more people to stay at home and
some fraction of those people aren't
actually going to be sick so those
people might feel frustrated by that
it's just it's a bigger bigger deal so
what's important to note is that in this
particular paper that we're talking
about today
the researchers only model the effects
of isolation and the use of contact
tracing to to perform isolation we are
not applying the approach of quarantine
within this paper great so the next key
term that we're going to define is this
term contact tracing which is in the
title of the paper and is the main thing
that we're trying to figure out the
efficacy of so the way that contact
tracing works is you again have this
example where you have a single infected
person who has four people that they
come into contact with regularly and
have a chance of passing the disease on
to and the way that this works is you
put this person in the system they get
diagnosed with cope at 19 and then you
have someone else in the system yet
or a government building something like
that you have a dedicated staff of
people who are responsible for figuring
out who this person has contact with
regularly and then actually calling them
you know every day every few days and
asking each time are you sick
while this other person gets put into
isolation so these people are free to
walk around they can do whatever but
they have to be asked every so often hey
do you have symptoms of copán 19 you
have a fever do you have a dry cough etc
and they'll say yeah I'm fine yeah I'm
fine or they'll say oh you know I have a
dry cough but maybe it's nothing and
that person will say no go into
isolation you've cut contact with
someone who has Kovac 19 you know please
remove yourself from the general
population and then they do that but
you'll probably notice that you know
this is requiring that people are
reporting their symptoms accurately
which was not always going to happen and
also if you have people who get less
sick because of kovin 19 you're not
necessarily going to catch those people
if you have someone who thinks they have
allergies for example but like the dry
cough that they always get once a year
turns out this time to be Co up at 19
you're still gonna have that person
walking around and you're going to be
spreading that to other people in your
simulation so it seems like there's some
potential for contact tracing to to be
an effective tool right we're preventing
some amount of disease spread but how
much disease spread how so if we want to
try and actually end the pandemic how
good desert what our contact tracing
need to be so in this model that the
investigators put forth they are going
to run a simulation for four months and
their definition of success within this
simulation is if they are able to by the
fourth month have stopped all spread of
the disease so in the fourth month there
are no new cases so to
you ate this you know there's a lot of
different factors that might affect
whether or not our contact tracing is
effective so we're going to talk about
those next and so these are things that
the researchers have to explicitly
explicitly define within the model great
so the first thing we want to talk about
before we start talking about all of the
different things that got tested in the
simulation is we want to talk about the
assumptions of this mathematical model
obviously these like little people and
they have this same chance of passing on
the disease to these other little people
this is not 100% accurate to what is
happening in real life the goal is to
get this as close to reality as possible
and in doing so you really want to be
able to define what you're assuming to
be true that might not be true in real
life so that you're being very specific
about what you're actually testing so
the four assumptions that we want to go
over before we get into the different
model parameters are these four here the
first is all symptomatic individuals are
eventually identified so this means that
if you have Coke in 19 like the system
is going to pick you up and they're
going to say this person had cope in 19
you're going to get added to that you
know total number of people who ends up
with the disease
the second is that infected individuals
can't infect anyone else once they're in
isolation so isolation is total and
complete there is no chance of someone
who's in isolation you know leaving the
house for a few hours and infecting
someone else that's not going to be
accounted for in this model they're also
not modeling other interventions such as
mask wearing or social distancing that
might decrease the spread of the
pandemic disease and for there are no
constraints on the tracing capacity so
when I talked about before how you have
this person from like the hospital who's
calling all these different people who
have contact with this infected person
you're saying that there are enough
people that they are getting as many of
the contacts as possible that you don't
have you know just one person trying to
get every
and then they can't so we're assuming
that there's enough people to trace
everyone okay so so those are the things
that we're going to hold constant
through all of our simulations and you
know obviously some of those assumptions
are not actually true in real life but
in real life the situation is so complex
that it's really hard to tease apart
what effect any particular factor or any
particular decision has on the system as
a whole
so by this using the simplified model we
can look at the effect of these four
particular variables on the outcome of
our contact tracing scenario so the
first parameter that the researchers are
explicitly going to look at the effect
of is the number of initial pieces so
it's important to note here as a bit of
background that this paper was actually
first posted online in was written at
the start of February so this paper was
written several months ago it was
published in a journal at the end of
February and so the use scenario that
they were envisioning for this research
was actually in trying to prevent the
spread of the disease internationally so
they were trying to model specifically
could contact tracing be used to prevent
the spread of a disease in a country
that doesn't already have the disease
but which is getting some imported cases
so you know we'll see here clearly that
the number of initial cases will have an
effect on art the efficacy of the
contact tracing if there's only one
initial person then there's less tracing
that you have to do whereas you might
have two initial people or four initial
people or you know evidence is emerging
it seems that I know in the UK that like
actually the disease was introduced
maybe up to for more than a thousand
times individually so in this case
they're they're modeling low numbers
compared to what we have seen over the
last few months but they're going to
specifically model the instances of five
initial cases twenty initial cases and
initial cases so you'll see those here
written on the slide the second
parameter and so parameter is sort of
this term that we use to describe
factors that we're going to be varying
in our simulations so the second
parameter is this value called R naught
which you might be familiar with having
read about it in the news or if you
attended the d4p presentation on May
20th
this value is talked about in more
detail and so if you're interested to
learn more I'd suggest you go take a
look at that talk but just in short here
all we really need to know for this
paper is that are not tells us the
average number of people that an
infected person will pass the disease on
to so you know you could have an R
naught value of 1 which indicates that
you know if I'm infected I'm going to
infect it in fact one other person on
average here we have a case of are not
being 3.5 so this is one of the values
the researchers test in the paper
obviously you can't actually infect half
of a person so what this value of 3.5
means is that some people with kovat are
going to infect three people like in
this picture other people will infect
four people some people might infect one
person other people infect a lot of
people but on average the number of
infected of newly infected people will
be 3.5 so the authors here are going to
test the values of 3.5 2.5 and 1.5 for
this parameter and and it's it's sort of
important to note too that this
parameter is actually a there's a
there's a right number this is a
characteristic of the disease itself
it's not something that we can actually
really influence but at the start of the
pandemic especially it's it's not
immediately obvious what this number
truly is and so the researchers here are
testing multiple different values to
account for that uncertainty that we
have and as
we learn more and you know as
researchers have learned more over the
past months they've been able to get a
more accurate a more precise value for
that or not great the next parameter
that we're going to discuss is the onset
to isolation delay which is defined as
the period between a person becoming
infected and the time at which they
actually put themselves into isolation
so the way to think about this is you
have this infected person with these
number of contacts and the idea is to
figure out how many days on average it's
going to take a person to put themselves
into isolation and if you got infected
at step zero and don't put yourself into
isolation until like Step three
you're gonna infect more people on step
four if you're you have this many
contacts at step zero but you put
yourself the isolation by the first day
you're going to in fact fewer people
because you're gonna have less of a
chance of coming into contact with
people so later we'll look at onset to
isolation delays being on average three
days which is considered short or on
average eight days which is considered
long and the final parameter we're going
to discuss is the probability that a
contact is successfully traced which
again goes back to this idea that
contact tracing is not going to be 100%
successful so when you're calling these
people who have had contact with this
infected person some of the things that
could go wrong are you don't have enough
people who are dedicated contact tracers
who you know are going to be able to
call up every single person who's had
contact with someone who's been infected
so you might miss ten twenty thirty
percent of this person's contacts other
things that might go wrong are you
contact them and they say they're fine
and they're not fine
so we're encapsulating all of that in
this single parameter that is how
effective is our contact tracing
basically how many people are reaching
out to and they're giving us a correct
answer
and the probabilities that we're going
to use are 0 20 40 60 80 and 100
so we're going for a whole range because
this is the thing that we want to test
most this is the point of the paper is
to figure out how good does our contact
tracing need to be because if it needs
to be like immaculate perfect for it to
make any difference then it might not be
the best use of our resources because we
have to hire and pay like thousands and
thousands of people to call out people
who've had contact with infected persons
so these parameters that we've just
introduced and the specific values that
the the authors of this paper are going
to test how did they come up with these
values so they didn't guess randomly or
just make their own estimates what they
did was they read a lot of other papers
and they looked at the research of other
scientists who those other scientists
may have been more directly observing
the spread of koban 19 in different
areas of the world and so on this map
you'll see everywhere there's a blue pin
as a location of a group that had
performed other research that went into
other papers that the authors of this
paper cite in producing their data so
they took their values for these
parameters from all of these other
papers so how do we figure out how our
parameters affect the model so as we
talked about before since there's an
element of chance if you run a single
simulation with a single set of
parameters the outcome that you'll get
for that simulation is not going to be
the same every time so what the
scientists do is they pick a single set
of parameters so for here maybe they'll
pick the R naught value one point five
and they'll run their simulation and
they're going to run that same
simulation 1,000 times so that's the
number of times that the researchers in
this paper actually ran each simulation
was 1,000 and then they're going to
change
are not value from 1.5 to 2.5 and then
they're going to run the simulation
another thousand times and they're going
to do this for each possible value of
each possible parameter and as we see on
this next slide if we're interested in
looking at the relationship between the
R naught values and the outcome of and
if we're trying to answer the question
of how good does our contact tracing
need to be under these different are not
scenarios then we're gonna bury both the
value for R naught as well as our
percent of contacts traced so you'll see
that this this multiplies very quickly
and each one of these stacks represents
a thousand different simulations so
these researchers really ran a lot of
simulations and that's why it's really
essential that we have computational
systems to help us do it because this
the scale of this would just not be
feasible to do by hand and so on the
next slide I think we're gonna show you
this is what the code actually looks
like this code is available online this
is the code that the research is used to
run the simulation so if you have any
familiarity with our eye you can you can
go and download this to yourself and run
this yourself but you'll see here on the
next slide that this one line of code
right here at the top this is actually
where we input all of the values for our
parameters so you'll see on the top line
there the number of initial cases here
is set to 1 so that's how the
researchers actually alter the
parameters and then they'll press run
and the simulation will run and what the
computer will do is it'll split out this
graph that's on the bottom right so this
was just an example that we ran but each
of these different colored lines is the
okk output of the same the same
different repetitions of the same
simulation so these all have the same
input parameters but you'll see that
each time you run it we get slightly
different outcomes but what we're going
to try and do and what we're going to
show you next is when you do
multiple times you're still gonna be
able to see patterns in the outputs also
mention I have the code downloaded this
is a screenshot of like my art studio so
if people when we do the QA want me to
run a few simulations with different
parameters just drop what parameters you
want me to run in the QA and we can we
can look at that alright let's get to
the paper finally so we're gonna show
you a series of graphs that are a
representation of all of the thousand
simulations so every data point here as
a thousand simulations averaged out and
these are all going to start to look
fairly similar because they're looking
at how good your contact tracing needs
to be varied with all of these different
parameters we just talked about so this
first one is the effect of your value of
r-not which was again the average number
of people that an infected person is
infecting so this has to do with how
infectious your disease is on the y-axis
we have the simulated outbreaks
controlled as a percentage so for their
thousands of simulations on average you
know 40% of them are being controlled
60% of them are being controlled etc on
the x-axis we have the percentage of
contacts traced so this is for a given
infectious person how many people are we
actually contact tracing out of that
enough total number of people what is
that percentage and then our key is our
reproduction number which is the same
thing as our knot and we've got a value
of 1.5 which is the bright red 2.5 which
is the black and 3.5 which is the
burgundy and so the first trend we can
look at here is something you'd probably
expect if you are tracing more if the
contacts you are controlling more of
your diseases if you are tracing none of
the context you are controlling a lot
fewer of you your pandemics and then the
only thing to see is your it is harder
to control pandemics that are that have
a high value of r-not because you're
infecting more people so they're more in
fact
Jesus than if you have a lower value of
r-not up here in the red and the other
thing I want to draw your attention to
is the fact that the Spurgin D line
which is the highest are not value has
this really exponential look to it
and this means that for any drop in your
percentage of contacts tres4
and are not value greater than 2.5 3.5
around in there you get this exponential
and you'll see here in 3.5 it's very
extreme you're you go from when you're
tracing 100% of your contacts you're
controlling almost 100% of your
outbreaks and if you drop to 80% you are
controlling less than half and then it
just gets worse and worse and worse so
you're controlling almost none if your
outbreaks so your contract tracing has
to be very very very effective if your
reproduction number is this high okay so
the second parameter that we're gonna
look at is the effect of our onset to
isolation delay so remember this is
basically how long does it take someone
to realize that they're sick and decide
to go into isolation and so compared to
that are not crafts that we just looked
at something important to keep in mind
is that that are not parameter is fixed
it's a characteristic of the disease
itself this parameter that we're looking
at is something that we actually have
control over so again the graph that we
have here the axes are the same as the
last graph that we looked at and you'll
notice that the general trend is also
similar of course as we trace more
contacts we're going to control more of
the infectious outbreaks but it's
interesting to look at what difference
this this particular delay makes so if
on average people wait only three days
if it only takes them about three days
to realize that they're sick and to you
know buy their groceries and stay at
home then you'll see I think the biggest
difference we can really look at
obviously here is it 80% of contacts
traced so if people are are making only
this short delay then we see that with
80% of the contacts traced we're able to
control about 90
percent of the simulated outbreaks so we
have a really good chance of controlling
the outbreak in this scenario why it
people are taking just like a couple
days longer to realize they're sick or
make the decision to stay home then we
drop to less than 40 percent so now
we're under we're more likely than not
not going to control the outbreak so
that's a that's a pretty if you think
about the effects of that on the
societal level that's a pretty big big
difference and so of course you know
this isn't our y-axis here is our the
the percent of simulated outbreaks
controlled so this isn't necessarily
saying that the percentages would be the
same if enacted in society but it's
giving us a sense of how sensitive is
our efficacy to this particular variable
so we see that there is some degree of
sensitivity and that it actually does
matter how long it takes people to make
that decision to stay home so the last
parameter they're going to look at is
one that we haven't discussed yet but
that you may have been thinking about
which is the fact that you have an
incubation period when you get the virus
and you don't have symptoms but there is
some amount of infectivity meaning you
can pass on the virus
so transmission before symptoms here is
expressed as a percentage and this is a
percentage of the infectivity that you
would have once you do start expressing
symptoms because this is you know an
airborne virus and if you're coughing
you're more likely to spread it so this
transmission is a percent of the total
transmission when you do actually get
the virus so we're looking at less than
one percent so very low transmission
before symptoms 15 percent in 30 percent
again you see the same trend it's high
over here and low over here because as
you're tracing more contacts you are
more likely to control your simulated
outbreak and this might be starting to
get redundant because you have the same
as you get more and more infectious and
you're passing on the virus more and
more you have this
potential drop-off where you really have
to trace a very large percentage of your
contacts in order to control an outbreak
so even if you just have 30 percent of
the actual transmission before you have
symptoms so people aren't in isolation
or anything we're just walking around
but they're less infectious you still
have this like big big drop-off as
you're tracing fewer of your contacts so
this has a pretty pretty intense effect
on the outcome of the simulation because
this is allowing more people to get
through the system because the system
can't catch people who are not showing
symptoms because this is how contact
tracing works so what are the takeaways
what can we do what can be done so we
looked at the Arnott and the
pre-symptomatic transmission which are
characteristics of disease is disease
itself and we can't control their impact
we could control things like forcing
people into quarantine on a policy level
but as individuals which I'm assuming
all of us are just individuals walking
around in society we cannot control the
infectivity of a virus but we can
shorten the delay from the symptom onset
isolation and this has a huge impact on
the spread of the virus so the main
takeaway is if you don't feel well even
if you just have a cold and you think
it's you know allergies or something
just just stay home if you can stay home
please stay home and the big other
policy thing that we should be doing is
we should be quarantine or at least
testing non symptomatic contacts because
based on this paper contact tracing even
when you're starting with so few initial
cases it is not controlling pandemics
and because the contact tracing has to
be so effective and like realistically
we are not going to be getting 80% of
our contacts traced